okay so donald trump is not in fact
orange hitler for not calling him
president-elect joe biden
or for not starting the transition right
away but the left is fully invested in
this narrative
that donald trump is hitler because this
justifies them doing whatever they can
in order to stop donald trump it
to undermine institutional credibility
of the media
of government and they're doing it full
scale okay so here's a great example jim
clyburn
right well-respected democrat probably
one of the leading forces behind joe
biden being president
if it had not been for jim clyburn
stumping for support for joe biden in
south carolina very good shot that
bernie sanders
might have been the nominee inside the
democratic party so jim clyburn
was talking yesterday on cnn about the
about the unwillingness of donald trump
to declare joe biden the president-elect
and this is pure ridiculous hysteria he
compares
donald trump to adolf hitler now
quick rule of thumb most of the things
that you don't like
have nothing to do with hitler things
can be things that are bad and also have
nothing to do with hitler in fact nearly
everything in your entire life that you
don't like
will not be hitler it turns out that
hitler is basically hitler
and not tons of other hitler's out there
thank god but here was jim clyburn
comparing donald trump to hitler
for not rec for not recognizing that joe
biden is president-elect of the united
states
there are many historical problems with
this particular narrative
one one of them is that adolf hitler
actually was
elected in november of 1932 to head the
largest party in the reichstag
and then he was asked by the by the
president of germany by by hindenburg
who was the acting head of state to form
a coalition government
and then hitler took power and then
liquidated all of his enemies it turns
out donald trump hasn't done any of
those things
but jim clyburn compares him to hitler
anyway because if you call somebody
hitler that means that you can do
whatever the hell you want and lie as
much as you want
i'm beginning to see what happened in
germany back in the 1930s
i never thought that could happen in
this country how do you elect a person
president then all of a sudden give him
the authority
to be dictator that's what we're teaming
on here
that's what hitler did in germany he was
elected chancellor
and then because he uh successfully
discredited
the news media took over the churches
what now uh this is not anything like
what hitler did
in germany like zero zero things are
currently held in common
i'm sorry nobody was talking about hey
hitler you lost an election
would you like a hundred million dollar
book deal and then hitler was like oh
okay
no no that that's not what happened when
everything is hitler nothing is hitler
and by the way this is deeply
deeply disgusting on virtually every
level
as a member of the jewish community i
know many people who have tattoos of
numbers in their flesh thanks to hitler
comparing donald trump to hitler because
he won't say that old doddering joe
biden isn't president-elect yet
spare me spit it's just
self-justificatory nonsense
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content